The only difference between the sexes is
socially constructed obstacles. You are,
well,
gender's construct gender itself.
It is. They should come here and take a
look at your place. That would shut them.
Shut the argument. That's
all male, male, gender.
I've got some female stuff here from when
my kids come over tonight. Tempa tell,
tell them what you said to me when I
say what a fucking great place. Oh,
this is what happens when women
don't get to tell you what to do.
A place you have a warehouse of mail,
but this looks,
that's not a nice guy. That's not bad.
And it's been a problem in this society.
Male energy, male thinking, male,
and he is vilified and you're,
you're taught to think that it's
something wrong with being masculine.
Being masculine is the reason why we don't
speak German. Okay, stop. Uh, exactly.
Talk about toxic masculinity. You could,
you will be the poster boy for that Shit.
Well,
the whole reason why you need male
people is because there's mail people,
other places that will take away your
shit and kill your people. And exactly.
This is not a bad thing.
Male does not equal evil.
Just because there are evil men, they are
evil men. Doesn't mean all men are evil.
There's evil women too. It doesn't mean
all women are evil. I dated three of them.
I bet he did it more than three, let's be
honest. Yeah, no, you're absolutely right.
But this toxic masculinity that
is his fuss Solera like you said,
really World War Two,
however there turned out well,
there's just so many dumb phrases like
that, you know, will they made up,
do you know about heteronormative?
I'm sure he knows his CIS gendered.
CISGENDER.
Hetero normative. Yeah. Like
you're, you're imposing the norms.
Like as if heterosexuality is normal.
Well,
did you see what was the story a couple
of days ago and I was in California here,
a beautiful state of California.
They're trying to the heat.
You can't say he or she gets they
now lat. Yeah. Where everywhere.
I'm saying what I'm saying. She,
Hannah something Jackson. He uh, yeah.
Now you have to say they nope. And they
were passing it. They had her in the,
the meeting, uh, the actual,
uh, town hall. A city.
Where are they passing the ordinance?
And at the end she goes, my, my grandma,
my grammar teacher wouldn't approve
of that. She's rolling around her,
but we won't hear from her.
She said her and somebody called
her out on it as she was passing the
nonsense. You shouldn't buy your
grandmother. She's not here.
It was corrected to
dentification densification.
Of course she looked like no Gingrich.
This,
she is California state senator bans
the use of he and she during committee
hearings. Oh look at her with her
perfect fucking little real haircut.
Newt Gingrich's haircut pow. It's
facing. Some people are just hilarious.
But they called her out. She's trying to
do a good thing though, you know, and uh,
they call her. They had a laugh
about it. But uh, that is so funny.
Who the fuck does she look like? Oh my
God. We wouldn't be hearing from her.
Well,
you made me.
That's what was in interrupted
by listeners who corrected
her usage and demand.
Oh, stop, stop, go back.
Corrected her usage and demand that
she used the word they or them,
they demanded. See this is the problem
with all this shit. Yes, it's demanding.
They're trying to control people or
telling people what to do, what not to do,
and it's about power.
A lot of this stuff is about power on as
they're imposing their worldview on on
you, but it's not even their
worldview. It's not real.
What it is is they're just deciding that
this is a thing that they're going to
agree to and they're going to force other
people to comply. It's half the game.
Half the game is just getting
people to comply. Well,
you do that by and you
start with language.
You control people's
behavior through language,
which is the definition of
political correctness. Well,
that's what Carlin always said that
fascism is just political correctness with
good manners are political correctness
is fascism with good manners.
How bout you saw the clip a Louie had
governors when he was talking about this,
how the, you know the millennials,
whoever demanding what we call them.
Yes, they are them I, and he goes, okay,
I'm, Louis Goes, okay, I'm a location.
It's your mother's car.
And he goes,
I got to come up with something more
clever and not as harsh, whatever. Yeah.
I'm a location. Your mother's gun. Yeah.